imagine walking your dog eight hours a
day
across 35 different countries meet tom
and his dog savannah
she's ready they are doing just that
[Music]
together they've walked 18 000 miles
over the past five years
i wanted to be off the beaten track i
wanted to have adventure
walking was the solution to that
[Music]
when i was 17 my close friend emery died
suddenly i realized how fleeting life
was
and how i needed to make the most of
things
what i wanted to do was to travel and
to experience humanity in the deepest
most immersive way possible
on his 26th birthday tom packed a
sleeping bag
an extra pair of shoes and a few
essential items and left the comforts of
his new jersey home
to embark on this journey
oh and day five my ankle
is wrapped up it's all swollen right
there
after four months of walking on my own
camping in strange places and
waking up in the middle of the night i
realized it would be really nice to have
a dog with me
so when i got to austin texas i went to
an adoption center
what's up savannah
[Applause]
there she is from texas tom and savannah
crossed their first border
into mexico mexico was the first foreign
country that i was walking through so it
was an
onslaught of new experiences new sounds
there's the beautiful city after walking
24 miles a day
for 72 days they made their way into
south america
where they faced some challenges
costa rica became the most challenging
walking
that savannah and i experienced the
walk-in has been really tough
super humid down here it was 100 degrees
100 humidity
walking through jungle there's no wind
and then
in chile savannah sneezes and her nose
starts to bleed
savannah almost died from a tick bite
luckily some locals helped them get to a
vet and she recovered
through moments like these tom began to
realize the power and beauty
in the kindness of complete strangers
one evening in the middle of the desert
savannah and i came to
a crossroads where there was a little
restaurant and nothing else around
and when we asked if we could stay there
for the night
the owner gave us dinner and put us up
and so it seemed no matter how far we
were from everything
someone was always there to help us
day 7.99
i am pretty tired she's not tired
never tired she is never tired
this pair of shoes they are fairly
destroyed after two years of walking
they took a boat antarctica
before picking his wall back up in
europe and continuing east
[Music]
italy provided everything in abundance
beautiful landscape and food and culture
every little village is just more
beautiful than the next
croatia was a magical place turkey
it was one of the most beautiful warmest
places that savannah and i crossed
today tom and savannah are currently in
baku azerbaijan
they have 2 years and 7 000 miles of
walking to do
when i began the journey i thought i
knew a lot about the world
i thought i knew a lot about myself i
didn't know how much i didn't know
passing through
little villages in the desert in the
mountains
in the jungle you realize
the surface level things change but all
anyone really wants to do is make a
little money
and spend time with her family that's
universal
you